the Prince of Wales coming close to the
Ukrainian border and a secret visit to
jejov it's where many Western weapons
arrive before being moved into Ukraine
and these are the British troops based
there just a big thank you for what you
do on a day-to-day basis you're doing a
really important job out here and
defending our freedoms is really
important impromptu thanks from the
prince who praise the collaboration
between the British and their polish
counterparts this was a chance to meet
both units with Prince William warmly
welcomed by the Polish defense minister
the soldiers here are part of Poland's
territorial Defense Force delivering Aid
and assistance to Ukraine
the prince we're told also wanted to
shine a light on the refugee crisis and
so to Warsaw and a center housing and
helping those who fled Poland has taken
in one and a half million ukrainians
including Natalia from Keith
she says it was a surprise but a
pleasure to host him in her room and
they spoke about her journey from
Ukraine into Poland
Prince William says the Polish people
have shown inspiring Humanity this visit
is more than a show of solidarity for
those supporting Ukraine it is also
sending a strong message to Russia and
pitching the Prince of Wales firmly
against Putin's Invasion this is Royal
soft power playing out on a hard Global
stage and the conversations about
Ukraine will continue when the prince
meets the president of Poland Laura
bundock Sky News in Warsaw